oh this is interesting so i couldn't
find exactly where it was originally
posted because a lot of articles had
snippets of it but this is the only
place i could find all of the text
messages i'm not sure how it came out
but there are text message screenshots
between p davidson and kanye west yeah
and it it's essentially i assume kanye
released this because he keeps going man
you're doing a loss for publicity like
i'm not about i don't know eats somebody
close skeets
pete's friend yeah
which is funny can you please take a
second calm down it's 8 a.m and it don't
got to be like this kim is literally the
best mother i've ever met what she does
for those kids is amazing and you are so
[ __ ] lucky that she's your kid's mom
i just i've decided i'm not gonna let
you treat us this way anymore i'm done
being quiet grow the [ __ ] up he was oh
using profanity where you at right now
but in in
in bed with your wife
cool
happy to see you at a hospital in rehab
and you go same here it's wonders what
those places do when you get help you
should try it i'm in l.a for the day if
you want to stop being a little internet
[ __ ] boy and talk aggressive for pete
yeah um you don't scare me bro your
actions are so [ __ ] and bear saying
it's so sad to watch you ruin your
legacy on the daily and then connie says
you're more than welcome to come to
sunday service i'm with pete on this
because why don't we meet after sunday
service and saints game i'll be at the
beverly hills hotel we can have food and
talk it out in my room privately
one-on-one man-to-man because what are
you doing to your family's dangerous and
going to scare them for life please
handle these matters privately bro i beg
you he goes you want to see me come to
sunday service which is so stupid
but this isn't public dude i'm not here
for pictures and press which i'll see
all you care about mod for stanzo she'd
man up for once in your life that uh let
me help you man i struggle with mental
stuff too it's not an easy journey you
don't have to feel this way anymore
there's no shame in having a little help
you'll be so happy and at peace you have
no idea how nice i've been to you
despite your actions towards me i've
stopped snl from talking about or making
fun of you which they've wanted to do
for months i've stopped stand-up
comedians
um
i've stopped standing up comedians from
doing bits about you because i don't
want the father of my girls kids to look
bad out there i have your back even
though you treat me like [ __ ] because i
want everything to be smooth but if you
continue to depress me like you have for
the past six months i'm gonna stop being
nice
yeah man you're dealing with comics so
pete's gonna light you up has he been so
he's been really bad to pete the whole
time yeah he made a music video where he
showed pete's dead body wearing it oh
yeah he was like burying it and then and
then he did and then he did say if
anybody sees him call call him skeet on
the street and then and then kim was
like dude what you're doing is you know
because you know he runs with some tough
dudes i think they're god's disciples or
gangsters jesus yeah got disciples in
chicago at all that's kanye's crew so
kim was like yeah stop this it's
dangerous for pete you're gonna get
somebody hurt and then kind of come out
like hey nobody put physical hands on
them i'll do that if we need to
it's just not kind of this is just
what you're doing
is just a hurt individual
i think there might be a method to his
madness i think he's like look at me
trending i'm trending number one that's
kind of the a lot of this might just be
that do you think that's real and did
that really come from pete is that a
real text director because for him to
say
that that was very inconsistent with the
rest of the stuff
i think your eyes are fine i think it's
real because i think pete's taking so
much [ __ ]
because kim posted two finally
addressing that they're officially
together plus the real picture she did
on her profile right so they're it's
definitely i think it's pretty real
especially the way he was talking like
dude i'm staying here i'm not coming to
your [ __ ] public service like i'm not
doing any of that dude what do i do have
a cup talk at sunday service well he's
like i'm not doing this for publicity
man just meet me in person what's wrong
with you
yeah and then that kind of makes sense
what you're saying then brian because
it's like if he went to the sunday
service then there could be [ __ ]
paparazzi or whatever thing oh pete and
kanye but that's why he's saying that no
that goes against this thing yeah he's
saying oh pete's saying i'm not doing
this for felicia i'm not going to your
sunday service those cameras and
pictures yeah yeah they come to my hotel
room this is a private matter
but then he made it public that's what
i'm saying pete didn't make this public
he didn't blast that out somebody did
close to it someone did usually kanye
but they didn't have something it's
weird because the text messages are not
anymore but then kanye yeah which means
which means pete was it was from pete's
phone whoever screenshot i just love
that we're all talking about it like i'm
actually hated
i don't like it this is the first time
i've ever been interested in this pop
culture like drama but it's interesting
because i i was watching kanye because
my girl follows this stuff so i was
watching kanye he gets on instagram and
starts talking about like his entire
life it's unbelievable he's like oh yeah
so mario i told you guys blah blah blah
and then well guess what and he's just
keeping everybody abreast on
on on i think it's north and how he
doesn't get to see north and how can
which isn't true that's all that's true
no that's true
yeah i think it's breaking news that kim
is getting a protective order against
kanye currently i i think kanye really
struggles with mental health and it's
pretty evident in his rants and tweets
and stuff like that it's not good man he
needs it and then also the he needs a
lot of help and also the harassment of
kim like that's the that's what i'm
saying that's the best way to handle it
no that's and even kim just text them
offline like she's like hey man what are
you doing and he posts that and he posts
it yeah he puts you on it's not good man
i think i think he's really mentally ill
i think he's a genius i like connie but
this just ain't the way to handle it no
like you lost your girl man like that
[ __ ] you lost your girl maybe because of
this too like that's difficult
imagine dealing with that i don't think
she wanted to like have be broken up she
wanted to raise kids are so sweet man
it's such it sucks all the way around
well it's tough i like pete too it sucks
what else you gotcha